we are just days away from super bowl 56
where the los angeles rams will host the
cincinnati bengals the last super bowl
in l.a was nearly 30 years ago this time
around local and federal agencies have a
much bigger job preparing for potential
security threats earlier we told you
about a dhs warning that truckers may
try to block traffic around the stadium
carter evans spoke exclusively with
homeland security secretary alejandro
mayorkas about the preparations and he
got a first hand look from the sky and
the sea this morning he's outside sophie
stadium in inglewood just outside l.a
carter good morning to you
good morning tony on sunday tens of
thousands of fans will descend here on
sofi stadium but what they may not see
are the thousands of members of federal
and local law enforcement that are
working around the clock to keep the
super bowl and the surrounding areas
safe
1500 feet above los angeles agents from
customs and border protection are on
patrol in black hawk helicopters
when you're in the air here what are you
looking for any unusual movement of
people
um that just seems suspicious or odd
and the security perimeter for the big
game extends miles beyond sofi stadium
there are super bowl events all over
this city and customs and border
protection is watching over all of it
the crew of this helicopter is looking
for small aircraft moving low and slow
that could be a threat
any aircraft that looks like it's
heading toward our temporary flight
restriction area they're going to vector
our aircraft to go investigate the
situation
that pose any specific challenges when
you have to keep such a large area
secure i think the logistics
are incredibly challenging in an
exclusive one-on-one interview homeland
security secretary alejandro mayorcas
gave us a glimpse behind the scenes
where every day up to 400 trucks are
x-rayed at the secure compound
there are security efforts both seen and
unseen more than 2 000 people working 24
7 to make sure that 70 000 people
will watch the super bowl and enjoy it
safely and securely
and guarding the california coastline is
part of the mission
sofi stadium is many miles that way
what's the concern out here on the water
we feel we're that first line of defense
for any threat that could be coming in
from
offshore
agent evan wagley took us out on one of
cbp's high-speed boats where they patrol
waters off the massive ports of l.a and
long beach
this 1400 horsepower boat can go up to
70 miles per hour and speed is important
because if they see a suspicious vessel
they've got to be fast enough to catch
it
obviously if there's any boats that
stick out to us we're going to go board
those but we're also going to board the
ones that may not seem out of place
and to find them they can downlink video
from aircraft overhead
if they feel that there's a boat out of
place
they can vector us into that area and we
can stop them and board them as well
in less than a week away from the game
new potential threats arise daily the
anti-vaxx trucker rally in canada
they've made some threats to come down
here are you prepared for that
individuals have a perfect right to
exercise their first amendment rights
once they intervene
in other people's freedoms and liberties
it becomes a more complicated landscape
but we're working with law enforcement
to address any eventualities
now in a bulletin obtained by cbs news
the department of homeland security is
warning that a convoy of truckers could
lead the gridlock here in los angeles
and that could impact the super bowl the
agency doe does describe the plans as
aspirational and says there are no plans
of violence but of course they are
prepared for anything dana
well i mean aren't los angeles used to
gridlock yeah very true and in that area
especially they are carter i gotta say
uh looking like agent evans there in the
helicopter and on the boat and you might
have missed your calling
thank you very much it was a lot of fun
that's for sure
carter thank you very much you know
super bowls having covered so many of
them
that preparation starts so far in
advance and you forget about so many of
those people who are working to make
sure that we are it is so important it's
a post-9 11 reality